hello everyone I'm Antoine Hayek I'm a
PhD student at the University of Vienna
and today I will be talking to you about
a particularly tight bounce on the time
complexity of broadcasts and its
variants in Dynamic Networks
this work is joint work with Monica
hansinger and Stefan Schmitz
so first of all a quick background on
why we do this
um so first of all we're looking at
Dynamic networks which is a very nice
way for modeling real life networks and
Link failures in particularly we're
looking at highly Dynamic networks which
are a good way of representing Network
processes move around a lot like 5G or
4G networks self-driving cars and so on
and in Dynamic networks we look at
broadcast which is an information
dissemination problem and in general
information insemination is important to
be understood for distributed Network as
many algorithms from distributed Network
rely on information dissemination
and communication in general and
in particular for broadcast one direct
application will be consensus and also a
leader election
um so let's first start by giving the
model for uh information designation our
Network
um so we have a communication that
happens in synchronous rounds as you can
see here and we have a network that is
highly Dynamic that is
um the networks can be completely
different from around to another it's
not just some links that are failing and
some others that are appearing it's
rather completely different
and we are looking at the case where
each process wants to share its ID with
as many other processes as possible
um and so we can also we also consider
the case where each process can transmit
any information it has received from
other process in previous rounds so if
we give a small example here you can see
that in the first round process number
one shares its idea with process number
two
and then process three and four received
ID from process number two
N5 received the idea of process number
four
and then from one round to another no
process forgets anything so we can copy
the IDS that each process has received
in the previous round and then do
another communication round again
so here process three receives ID 1 2
receives the ID3 and here one
interesting thing happens is that
although process five already knew the
id4
um process number four cannot send the
id2 to process five and so process I
received the ID of two even though it
hasn't received directly any information
from process number two
and then we do that again for another
round so we keep what we already knew
and then we communicate again and here
another interesting thing is happening
that is process number four receives the
ID of 1 and 3 at the same time from
process number two uh similarly uh
process number one receives the ID 2 4
and 5 in a single round this is to show
that there is no limit on the message
size or the number of IDs one can
receive per round
um so in that model our objective is to
have as much IDs to submitted as
possible so as much communication
possible
um and so we want to analyze how long it
takes for information to be disseminated
um and we will be looking at the worst
case scenario
um or in other words we work in an
adversarial model where it will be an
adversary that will choose a network in
each round it will have a set a of
predefined network you can choose any
network from in any round and then
um so we will be talking about different
objectives
the main objective will be broadcast and
then we have two other variants and the
adversary will try to delay that
objective as much as possible and our
goal is to determine how many rounds uh
we need until or how many rounds the
industry can delay the objective
um and so we'll be looking at three
different problems the first problem is
broadcast on trees
um so the investor will be restricted to
rooted trees on end processes and the
objective will be that there is one ID
that is received by everyone that is
broadcast
and will show that this is this takes in
your time at most
similarly we introduce a variant for
broadcast which is K broadcast and we
look at K rooted networks so the
adversary will have to choose a network
we have which has K different routes
and the objective is that there are K
IDs that have been received by everyone
each
this again will be linear and then
finally we will be looking at the cover
of size K on K forests this time the
adversary will have to choose an each
round of forest that is the union of K
disjoint rooted trees and then the
objective will be that we have K
different IDs such that everyone has
received at least one of those case
um so we will go in details in each one
of them again and give examples if you
don't really see what's happening here
but for the general idea you can think
that K broadcast on K router networks is
basically a generalization of broadcast
on rooted trees where we forced the
adversary to use more connected networks
and then the objective is more ambitious
than only broadcast on the other hand
cover of size K on K Forest the
anniversary is allowed to give this
parser Network
however this time the objective is less
ambitious and will require less
information being disseminated in at the
very end as an objective
all right so we will start talking about
broadcast automated trees
um
so here we have a small example
um so the idea is that we have different
crowns in each round you can see that
the adversary chooses the rooted three
so one one and five are the roots so the
roots don't have to be the same each
round but we need to have one root in
each round and then in the end here you
can see that everyone has received the
ID to
um after three rounds so we say that two
has broadcast after three rounds
um and so the question is if we have end
processes how long can the adversary
delay
um
delay broadcast
um and to do this we have a main
observation that is if a root has
received an ID before the start of a
round then this ID is received by one
new process during this round
so if we look back at this example uh
here you what I mean is basically you
have to look at what happens at the root
so here the route has received id1 here
as well and here the root has received
the ID 5 4 and 2. and then in the first
round we can see that two receives the
ID one for the first time in that round
and the second round three has received
id1 for the first time in that round and
then in the last round five and four has
been received by Two For the First Time
whereas two has been received by process
number one
um and so we can generalize this
um the way to show this is to look at
the roots in around and then let's
assume it has received the IDE for
um and then assuming four didn't
broadcast yet you know that there is a
process p over here that didn't receive
the ID number four and then you just
look at the path from the root to that
process
um because the route has received the ID
number four and that process didn't
receive it you know that this path will
go from one node that has received id4
to a node that didn't receive it and so
this letter node will now receive the
id4 for the first time in that round
so what that means is that if we have an
ID that has been received by n different
routes this means that there are any new
process that that have received it and
in other words this means that this ID
has been received by everyone at that
point
um and this is the main idea of the
proof we will keep track of the IDS the
root have received before each round and
um we will show that there is an ID that
has been received by n different routes
and this will essentially be the the
proof
um now to show that there is an ID that
has been received by n different rounds
we create a new graph
so this new graph has n nodes one each
uh one for each process
and then one node for each round up to
three and rounds
and then we add an edge from an ID to
around if the root of the round has
received the ID so here
you can see the ID of the the
root of the first round has received ID
one one three two one and two one and
this is the edges that we find here
again so we have that the first round
received the ID of 1 and an edge from
id1 to round number two on an edge from
one two and three to round number three
and an edge from ID 1 and 2 to round
number four
and then we also add an edge from one
round to a round that is larger
if the larger round has received the ID
of the root of the first one so this is
what I keep here this is the ID of the
root right
um one one three and two one one three
and two and then because two three and
four has have received the ID of one we
add an edge from round number one to
them similarly we add an edge from two
to three and two to four because one is
the ID of round number two and has been
received by rounds three and four
foreign
some observation on that graph uh the
first one if a node has a degree at
least N Out degree at least and then the
corresponding idea has reached everyone
that is because if you have an ID that
has a note edge to n different rounds
this means that
um
all these rounds the root have received
the ID and then by the observation we
did two slides ago this means that the
corresponding ID has reached everyone or
has been received by everyone
um on the other hand if there is a round
that has a degree n
that means that the corresponding idea
of the root has been received by n
different routes in other Realms and
that also means that this
um this ID has been received by everyone
um now so the only thing is to find or
to prove that there is a degree
um that is larger than an art degree
that is larger than in that graph
um so one thing you can see is that uh
round one has in degree one round two
has in degree two round four has in
degree four and then round three has in
degree larger than three that's five
here
um and that is something you can prove
which I cannot do here
um so round T has a degree at least T
and then you can count the edges by
counting the in degrees
um
and then so the total number of edges is
larger than the sum of T over all the
rounds which is equal to nine N squared
over two
rather carefully you have four n nodes
total which means that the average
degree
um is 9 over 8 and which is larger than
n and that means that there is at least
one node without degree larger than and
that node its corresponding ID will have
broadcast
um
um so this is
um a simple proof
um if you look more into the details of
that graph you can actually show that we
actually have a node without degree n as
soon as n is larger than 2.4 n
so this is another round for us which is
2.4 n and then there is a lower bound so
you can imagine just having a chain
graph that is a line line graph uh that
is the same for all the rounds and that
will take n minus one rounds to
broadcast
um we can actually find a better lower
bound and that is due to designer shorts
and Schmidt which is roughly 1.5 n
rounds
so that was it for broadcasts let us
know talk very quickly about K broadcast
on camera networks
um so key broadcast this time the
adversary has to choose networks which
have K roots in each round
and then the objective is that we have K
IDs that have been each received by
everyone
so here we have a small example you can
see that in each round the adversary has
to choose at least two routes so that
those are two nodes that can reach
everyone
and then the objective at the end is
reached because
um one and two
have been received by
all the processes after three rows so we
have two broadcasts and three rounds and
the broadcasters are one and two
um I will not go into details of the
proofs of
um of why this upper bound is linear
because it's very similar to broadcast
um so this is linear as well and the
lower bound as well as very similar to
the previous lower bound
um or another easy way to see this is
just take a cycle of length n and then
repeat that over all the rounds and then
you can see that you cannot
have broadcast in fewer than n minus one
or else
um okay let's now talk about cover of
size K on K forests so this time the
adversary has to choose a forest with uh
which with carotid trees and then the
objective is that we have K different
IDs such that everyone has received at
least one of them
um so here I have a small example in two
rounds you can see that the adversary
chooses a forest with two trees in each
round and then at the very end everyone
has received the ID of either one
or two
um so we say that we have a cover size
two and two rounds
um so this time the way this works is
instead of going forward in time and
trying to understand what happens when
we add around uh after previous rounds
this time we start at the very end and
then we go backwards in time and trying
to understand what happens if we add
another round previous to all the
current
um
communication routes
um and so you can see here that we start
with all the different processes each
one has received its own ID so this is
nice and then we go back in time until
there is uh one process such that there
are two other
um
processes that has received its ID
and so we know that if we take into
consideration the rounds from t n minus
1 to TN then this idea will have reached
these two processes and then we go back
in time further and further and then we
can find another process that can reach
two other processes
similarly between rounds tier minus 2
and TN and then what's interesting is is
if we go back further then we find a new
process that can send its ID to one
other process before round Tien which is
fine however it can also send its ID to
process BN minus 1 before round 10 minus
1.
and so you can imagine that
since p n minus 1 can send this id2
processors 1 and 3.
and then PN minus 3 can send its id2pn
minus 1 and 10 minus 1 instead of
sending its own ID it can send the ID of
PN minus three to three and one and then
if we look at
all the rounds between t n minus 3 and
10 then PN minus 3 can reach 4 3 and 1.
and so on and so forth and this is very
interesting because if you look at all
the IDS at the at only time TN this is a
cover of size n which is larger than
what we want we want a cover of size K
but then if we go to T N minus 1 and
replace one and three by PN minus 1 then
this is a cover of size n minus 1 and
then at n minus two if we replace 5 and
2 by again minus 2 this is a cover of
size n minus two and then if we remove
BN minus 1 and add BN minus three then
this is cover of size n minus three and
so on and so forth
and so this is the main idea we start
with the cover size and that is all the
different IDs and then we go back in
time and we find smaller and smaller
colors
um and then so we keep track of these
different times and then we Define TI to
be the time where we are down to its
size 2A cover size I
and then the difference between two
consecutive times is going to be Delta I
and you can see that if we sum all the
Delta I's from I is equal to K up to n
this will be the times were where we are
down from this cover of size n to a
cover of size K which is exactly what we
want so we will try to find a bound on
the sum of the Delta I's and actually
what we will be able to find is some
bounds on Delta I's first
and then this will translate into a
bound on the sum of the device
um so I will not go into detail of on
how we found the bounds on the Delta I's
but I will show you the very neat
structure the Delta eyes have
so this is about the Delta ice photo
this is a bit hard to sparse what you
might want to know is that this term
over here is essentially the weights of
the edges over here and then we have a
pretty neat representation of what such
a constraint means
um so if you look at the particle node
like this one and then you look at all
its in edges then this constraint here
means that if you multiply the well
Delta 5 plus K times 1 and then add
Delta four plus K times 2 and then add
Delta 3 plus K times 3 then this is
going to be smaller than n
um and this is true for every node so if
you take if you look at every node and
then you look at their images and you
multiply each weight of an edge by its
tail and add everything together then if
you sum that it must be smaller than
um
now this is very neat however it's not
very useful as is
um
so what we do is we we show that this
implies another
another set of constraints on the
on on the Delta ice which is more more
useful
um so we can show that this implies this
over
well this constraint and what this
constraints means is that if you
multiply a node by its out degree and
add that to the same thing for all
smaller nodes so here you can see we
have Delta 1 times 1 plus Delta 2 plus K
times 2 plus Delta 3 plus K times 4 and
so on and so forth so
this is going to be smaller than 3 times
n and if we add one node further this
will be smaller than 4 times n and so on
and so forth
um and thus we have these all these
different constraints over here and so
remember we want to give an upper bound
on the sum of the Delta I's
um so the maximization station problem
is to maximize the Delta I's and then we
have all these constraints
um we can show that the maximum is
reached when the constraints are
actually equalities
and then this is pretty easy to solve
um so we have each Delta I is
n over I squared and then if you sum all
the Delta I's
then if you you can take the N Out and
then you're just summing one over I
squared and this converges so we can
upper bound this by the sum
from I is equal to 1 to Infinity of 1
over I squared then that will be linear
so this is the main idea for the upper
bound
um and then similarly the lower bound is
pretty similar to the previous lower
bounds
um one way you can you can imagine this
is just isolating every vertex in a
trivial tree except for the last three
which has all the other vertices make a
chain in that last three and that tree
will have n minus K vertices so
um
we will have cover in N minus K rounds
so a quick recap
um so we had broadcast on rooted trees
um this is linear we show that this is
linear which closes a conjecture that
was given by zarnish fund's mix
and
um
2019
um
and then we introduced two other
variants that are K broadcast on K
rooted networks and cover size K and K
forest and showed this as well as linear
um
so we the main takeaway is to say that
in when in the worst case scenario when
there is enough connectivity
um and when there is no limit on the
message sizes then data dissemination is
linear
um and then
some future work this includes finding
ways to speed up the objectives if we
want to have faster little dissemination
uh then how can we constrain the
adversary differently
another option would be to look at
random anniversary instead of a smart
one that would be more
that would model better maybe the real
world networks which are usually not
perfectly for serial we can also look at
applications like leader election or
consensus and we can also look at what
the message size if we can stream the
message sizes what happens
um well um this is the end of the video
video I hope you enjoyed it and
um I invite you to read the paper if you
are interested in this work